[Musique]
Bonjour à tous bienvenue sur le plateau
de la grande interview avec aujourd'hui
Jean-Pierre Raffarin merci monsieur le
Premier ministre
Bonjour Merci à vous avez été Premier
ministre de Jacques Chirac c'était en
2002 2005 exactement ce que les choses
ont changé depuis ça va
alors votre parcours il est
impressionnant encore
de votre de votre chemin
et puis après
évidemment aussi
et puis et puis
c'est
une alternance entre l'entreprise et
j'ai passé le
Mitterrand de manière très heureuse à
diriger le cabinet Bernard ça y est je
me souviens je me souviens activement
que vous étiez au chevet d'internet de
chef d'entreprise conseil en management
absolument conseil pratique du chef
alors vous amène directement
un livre qui
choisir
une histoire
pour
est à l'école
depuis 15 ans et un peu ce sujet et
c'est vrai que c'est le sujet qui est à
la fois une jambe et une jambe dans la
politique parce que par définition le
leadership c'est comment un carnet une
destination 1 et comment trouver le
chemin qui va emmener les gens vers
cette destination en faisant sorte que
le chemin est la destination soit
cohérent c'est pas si facile que ça la
question que je voulais commencer par
vous vous posez elle est liée à
l'introduction
question est-ce que les qualités est-ce
que le parcours est-ce que l'expertise
dans l'entreprise comme dans la
politique ce sont les mêmes absolument
pas voilà un absolument pas parce que
justement et il y a dans l'entreprise
d'abord rien une chose qui est très
importante l'entreprise elle a une
culture de parcours vous passez de 35 %
part de marché à 37 à 40 à 42 mesures
mesures et ça continue vous avez des
hauts et des bas mais c'est continue en
politique il faut 50 % de part de marché
un certain dimanche entre 8h et 20h j'ai
deux rendez-vous
dans l'entreprise a une stratégie de
parcours en politique vous avez une
stratégie de rendez-vous en ce moment
une campagne présidentielle
la République n'est pas encore engagé
tout ça va se faire un moment où les
Français vont entrer dans la campagne
c'est la bonne gestion de ce rendez-vous
de la question importante et puis dans
l'entreprise on a plutôt dans la culture
du nom forcer les gens à se dépasser en
politique voulais pas un homme politique
qui dit non ou rarement il fait dire non
par son cabinet il fait dire non pas son
secrétariat il fait dire non par hier
mais globalement il ne dis pas non et
puis il y a cette grande question de
l'autorité le chef d'entreprise il a un
système hiérarchique en politique le
ministre les poils sur le député il faut
qu'on est le député donc c'est c'est
clair que les logiques de leadership
sont pas les mêmes et pourtant il faut
un carnet loreale. Car il faut aussi un
carnet un pays un corps d'une région à
carreler une ville l'incarnation c'est
ça les deux et c'est ça qui est très
important parce que les sujets sont de
plus en plus complexe comment faire
comprendre la complexité c'est
l'incarnation qui fait comprendre que la
carnation est plus importante que
l'expertise absolument l'incarnation et
être authentique avec la cource qu'on
défend
l'expertise est important mais
l'incarnation est un élément majeur
aujourd'hui de la gestion de la
complexité parce que un homme représente
une complexité un maire qui se retire
vous voyez deux adjoints qui se battent
ces deux adjoints il était et travailler
ensemble dans la main voilà et puis d'un
seul coup c'est parce que le leader il a
rassemblé alors je reviens sur ce que
vous dites à savoir que l'homme
politique il a une performance de
rendez-vous absolument je me permets de
vous dire quand même que très souvent
mais vous êtes passés par là en tant que
Premier ministre il a quand même le
rendez-vous tous les soirs avec le
journal de 20h et il a tous les jours
les sondages il regarde et regarder le
quinquennat de Macron il a été quand
même challenge et pratiquement tous les
mois c'est un grand sujet d'un contrat
sur
d'incompréhension entre la politique est
l'entreprise ce que vous dites la grande
journaliste économique c'est le monde
économique qui pense ça le monde
politique ne pense pas parce que je vais
vous dire le problème c'est que j'avais
le nez sur les sondages on va bien sûr
mais ce qui nous intéresse c'est la
dynamique quand vous êtes comme jusqu'à
que vous gagner l'élection 4 mois avant
ou que vous gagner les élections 15
jours après si vous la perdre et le jour
de l'élection le rendez-vous se saisir
le pignon un moment donné donc ce qui
compte aujourd'hui de manière important
c'est pas de dire Seymour ceci c'est
qu'est-ce que va devenir Zemmour c'est
la projection rugby c'est le coup de
pied à suivre il faut se trouve et là où
le ballon va retomber c'est donc la
projection et c'est une incompréhension
souvent entre la politique et citoyen le
citoyen qui regarde son journal de 20h
il a le sentiment il vote ce soir-là le
politique sais c'est pas ce que vous
pensez ce soir qui est important c'est
ce que vous allez penser dans 2 mois
vous pensez ce soir parce que ceci vous
a marqué tout ça mais dans 2 mois il y a
autre chose qui va se passer et donc ce
que je dois faire moins politique c'est
penser à ce que sera votre opinion le
moment venu alors qui a les qualités de
chef aujourd'hui
dans l'offre politique sur le marché
politique d'abord
d'abord le chef
c'est pas toujours vertueux il y a un
leadership c'est pas toujours ça peut
être vertueux quand c'est démocratique
quand c'est dans l'état de droite mais
si il y a des dérives par exemple
d'exercice Solitaire du pouvoir par
exemple clanisme mes amis sont bons mes
ennemis sont mauvais par exemple la
surexposition
l'usure la lassitude être toujours sur
le ventre donc ce qui est important
aujourd'hui c'est de voir en effet
comment on a les qualités personnelles
une pipe et comment on a les vertus
aujourd'hui par exemple si je prends
l'exemple du président Macron il a un
leadership très fort pourquoi il a cette
promesse politique est très rare en
politique français seul jusqu'à il y a
50 ans avec la même c'est d'être le plus
jeune le plus expérimenté quand
moi j'étais 11 ans ministre des Finances
et à l'expertise est là mais c'est la
capacité
avoir de la crédibilité et donc dans
cette logique là il est très important
que le chef puisse avoir une capacité à
convaincant vous voyez Mâcon qui à la
fois très jeune mais en même temps qui a
déjà été président pour le prochain
moment donc
c'est rare d'avoir déjà expérimenté
quand on est expérimenté le bilan
de l'importance
[Musique]
et
vous
n'avez pas le bon parcours est-ce qu'il
faut
parce que
elle
est
à tous les problèmes au jour le jour la
vraie conditions elle est dans la vision
est-ce que je veux une société de
liberté est-ce que je vais une société
de sécurité est-ce que je veux une
société territorialisée est-ce que je
veux une société centralisée donc la
vraie conviction elle est dans la
construction du modèle aller dans la
construction de la stratégie on fait
croire aujourd'hui que la politique 7 km
de trottoir c'est la petite promesse
opérationnel quotidienne non la
politique c'est la vision est la
capacité d'emmener les autres vers cette
destination le vrai débat politique
c'est un débat de destination ensuite
donc faut vraiment une cohérence et si
je prends grille de lecture mais là
c'est Mélenchon parce qu'il y a une
conviction
je reconnais qu'il a les talents de sa
cause mais sa cause des pas la mienne
donc la destination j' y a des repas il
y a le amour pour moi c'est un
leadership de circonstance je pense que
en fait je pense que Mélenchon il a un
leadership je dirais de conviction en
effet stratégique politique
dans
le marché
parce que
je pense que
je pense pas
parce que je
pense
je
suis
en premier grand je trouve qu'on voit
qu'il est qu'il est en progrès mais je
ne crois pas qu'il soit arrivé à un
point d'excellence en matière de
l'excellence aujourd'hui ça fait 50 ans
qu'il est dans la politique ou 40 ans je
le connais depuis très longtemps
donc on
n'a pas vu
bien sûr
même même Sarkozy l'avais déjà repéré on
lui confirmer une responsabilité de la
commission Nathalie donc
là on a vu qu'il y avait quelque chose
donc il est il est dans le vocal depuis
déjà une trentaine d'années et personne
n'a dit tiens voilà
partout dans le monde
avec
ses caractéristiques propres
et
disons que le leadership féminin dans le
monde aujourd'hui et émergent les
valeurs féminines dans la société sont
des valeurs de plus en plus présentées
prégnante et donc je crois que
Valérie Pécresse incarne bien ce
leadership et je pense que là elle a un
atout que tu en as tout ce qu'il faut
prendre en considération parce que elle
est bien dans sa peau avec ses valeurs
la elle est authentiquement un leader
féminin qu'elle assume et ça je pense
que c'est quelque chose qui va compter
alors on va revenir un peu sur le détail
des programmes parce que ça ça compte
quand même dans une campagne et plus ça
va aller plus ça va compter on s'arrête
quelques minutes et puis
[Musique]
retour sur le plateau de la grande
Interio avec Jean-Pierre Raffarin qui
connaît bien la vie politique qui
connaît bien la classe politique 7 faut
que vous écrivez avec beaucoup beaucoup
de Malice parfois avec un livre qui sort
la chez Michel Lafon choisir un chef
finalement les qualités qu'il faut pour
être chef qui sont bien différente de
celle qu'il faut pour exercer sa
fonction dans une entreprise absolument
je pense que il est il est très
important pour la politique d'avoir une
capacité d'entraînement bien sûr c'est
aussi important dans notre vie mais dans
l'entreprise de l'entreprise vous avez
quand même la hiérarchie qui est un
atout formidable pour l'action alors que
naturellement en politique il faut
toujours convaincre convaincre encore et
donc ça ça demande de la séduction de la
pédagogie de la capacité à s'exprimer de
l'usage de l'humour par un grand
chapiteau ça parce que l'humour c'est
très important pour pouvoir alors ce qui
est vrai évidemment démocratie avec un
système médiatique très mais c'est aussi
un peu vrai dans dans dans les systèmes
du monde qui sont un peu moins
démographique que les nôtres il faut
aussi convaincre le peuple de suivre le
chef
le chef de toute façon il a forcément
dans quelle que soit la Villa des rivaux
et donc forcément il y a il y a
compétition compétition sont différents
mais il y en a toujours besoin d'être
meilleur que les autres on voit en photo
avec deux anciens anciens reste Nicolas
Sarkozy il a pas des premiers ministres
République Jacques Chirac avec
Nicolas Sarkozy
c'est quelqu'un ça c'est un vrai 10h
regarde la manière dont tu il a dirigé
la présidence européenne pendant la
crise de 2008 là on avait un vrai leader
on peut dire sur votre Sarkozy mais mais
c'est un leader c'est que le régime
français permet à quelqu'un qui est
connu je parle de Manuel Macron de
sortir de l'eau et des présidents de la
République absolument c'est ça c'est un
peu le talent de de l'institution c'est
que les institutions avec cette élection
au suffrage universel mets le président
comme le meilleur et lui comme cela le
père de la personne qui a la plus large
basse politique et donc ça lui donne une
force une légitimité considérable on
discute beaucoup la légitimité des
parlementaires la légitimité du
président est très rarement contester un
instant il faut attendre de connaître le
détail du programme de Valérie Pécresse
vous le connaissez pas si vous allez je
connais mais surtout ce qu'il faut
attendre c'est le programme de Macron de
Macron Emmanuel Macron parce que je
pense Alexa qu'est-ce que vous voulez
dire la surprise je veux dire que cette
intelligence qui l'a mise 50 voir ça
doit produire un projet politique qui
sera super puissant je le pense je
souhaite à Paris j'ai pas de confidence
mais je pense que il doit voir un peu
les la montée de la violence dans la
société il voit sur en quoi la politique
n'est pas toujours légitime il doit voir
comment notre part le Mans aujourd'hui
n'a pas sa place dans nos institutions
de manière satisfaisante donc je pense
qu'on va avoir des propositions
institutionnel je crois qu'il y aura une
très forte ambition je pense que pour le
moment la campagne mais Christelle que
les thèmes sont sont présentés n'est pas
tout à fait la dimension de ce que sera
le printemps prochain la vraie question
pour nous c'est pas comme le dit c'est
Hollande le problème la finance le
problème c'est la violence comment
apaiser la violence dans cette société
c'est ça la grande question et pour ça
pour légitimer la police la politique
c'est la lutte contre la violence c'est
la règle pour l'apaisement c'est que le
fait qu'on vive ensemble et ça ça va
demander des réformes important dans un
grand nom de l'espèce ça nécessite par
exemple de reconnaître les corps
intermédiaires alors qu'il les a la mine
et je pense que il a sans doute je crois
que je suis d'accord avec vous sur la
décentralisation par exemple il n'a pas
été suffisamment Girondins je pense que
il a intégré tout ça on va le voir mais
si vous mettez une bonne intelligence
une grande capacité 5 ans dans le vocal
présidentielle sur l'objectif de
rendez-vous ça m'étonnerait mais ça
m'étonnerait que maintenant avec ce
rendez-vous là il va pas remettre sur la
table parce qu'il a toujours cette
jeunesse parce qu'il a le renouveau
parce qu'il est sans doute celui qui
comprend le mieux l'évolution de la
société donc je pense qu'il va nous
donner un projet qui sera un projet
audacieux est-ce que le deuxième mandat
ne libère pas le affranchis pas de la
contrainte des sondages quotidien et de
je pense je crois qu'au fond
quelquefois est assez impopulaire il a
il a il a su la Suède courageux et au
total je trouve que la gestion de la
crise sanitaire n'est pas si mauvaise
que ça quand je compare avec les pays
étrangers aujourd'hui est-ce que sa
conférence de presse annonçant sa
présidence est le programme de sa
présidence de l'Union européenne vous
donne des indications sur la politique
étrangère je pense que oui et est-ce que
pour vous c'est un Européen convaincu
parce que ça a toujours été votre combat
ça vous donne des perspectives
d'ouverture moi ça me donne à mon avis
je vois trois grandes orientations dans
ce qu'elle dégage aujourd'hui
donner un leader ship à l'Europe et ça
c'est le franco-allemand et là on a
peut-être une chance après le départ de
Angela mais avec le nouveau gouvernement
avec le nouveau gouvernement et on va se
retrouver avec 5 ans de stabilité
politique entre les le président de la
présence française et la présidence le
chancelier allemand il y en a sans doute
l'occasion de créer un nouveau couple à
la de gaulle-adenauer à la jusqu'à donc
je pense que ça ça c'est le 1er. Le
franco-allemand le deuxième. Et qui qui
me paraît très important c'est donc avec
les Allemands d'avoir un accord sur les
grandes puissances du monde alors
qu'est-ce qui peut se passer avec la
Russie par exemple parce que au début du
quinquennat on a vu un Emmanuel Macron à
c'est volontaire invité invité le
président Poutine à Versailles se rendre
à Saint-Pétersbourg
on était on était parti sur une ligne de
départ
on se met de de collaboration
je pense personnellement vérifier mes
intuitions mes informations me font dire
quand même que Angela Merkel a toujours
considéré car la semaine car ici c'était
une exclusivité allemand regarder et
quant à la conférence des ambassadeurs
il y a 2 ans Macron dit il nous faut une
nouvelle architecture de confiance avec
la Russie on voit la porte qui se ferme
avec l'Allemagne donc je pense
qu'aujourd'hui
le nouveau gouvernement allemand peut
avoir une attitude différente il ne peut
pas y avoir de sécurité en Europe sans
une relation apaisée avec la Russie la
question majeure de la sécurité en
Europe quand vous pensez que les Suédois
sont convaincus qu'on va faire une
guerre avec la Russie mais quand vous
pensez que les Polonais sont-elles des
Pays-Bas sont crevés on peut pas de vous
demander à la personne ne croit à la
guerre avec la Russie donc cette tension
là il faut pouvoir l'appeler c'est pour
ça ça demande à ce que l'Europe soit
plus européenne un peu moins américain
révision des accords de l'Auto je pense
que la souveraineté européenne dans tout
le monde parle aujourd'hui dans ma qu'on
a parlé cet souveraineté européenne ça
veut dire qu'il faut qu'il y a un accord
pour les relations avec les États-Unis
avec la Russie et avec la Chine ça ça
veut dire que de ce point de vue-là il
faut cesser d'être systématiquement
dépendant des Américains et construire
la sécurité en Europe sans qu'on ait
besoin systématiquement dessus et vous
avez un café et on voit bien aujourd'hui
que les Américains joue avec cette cette
cette idée de l'adhésion de l'Ukraine as
le temps un jour c'est non on dit non
mais en fait tomber le temps on fait
comme si c'était oui et donc on voit
bien que ça c'est c'est pas dans nos
accords et c'est quelque chose d'assez
agressive de la Russie donc il est clair
que le ce n'est pas l'objectif de
l'Europe l'Europe pas la guerre avec la
Russie donc c'est pas la guerre il faut
organiser la paix
au niveau international
est-ce que vous avez pendant des années
et des années assurer les relations
notamment au niveau commercial et
entrepreneurial avec la Chine vous êtes
encore aujourd'hui de mission par le
ministre des Affaires étrangères
bénévole mais
aujourd'hui
elle
est devenue l'élément dominant pour la
Chine
Internationale
des
États-Unis
les États-Unis
de la pression entre les et elle a pas
que votre interlocuteur là qu'on voit
magnifique sur cette photo là le
président chinois il a peut-être aussi
du souci avec sa population avec son
opinion publique
c'est très difficile dans les régimes
autoritaires de donc
aujourd'hui
contre les États-Unis et sur le fait que
ils sont tous les deux
donc on se voit dans cette situation là
et et ça c'est pas bon pour le moment la
seule réponse à ça c'est que ce qui est
au milieu c'est à la balle de ping-pong
c'est-à-dire nous. Je l'Europe l'Europe
qu'on soit puissante et qu'on soit
organisé et pour ça il faut de mon point
de vue un leadership franco-allemand de
l'Europe tant qu'on aura aujourd'hui il
y a pas de tête en dormant il y a pas
des heures mais donc le leadership
européen c'est le fond qui est dans le
franco-allemand ce qui compte
c'est la paix avec la Russie et c'est
une souveraineté qui fait que on a des
engagements avec les Américains mais on
ne peut pas au nom des Américains faire
la guerre à la chienne et donc nous
pensons que l'on demande travailler
notre entreprise ont besoin des marchés
chez toi la Chine est indispensable à la
croissance mondiale beau et réalisme et
donc il faut équilibrer les choses
n'ont pas fait quelque part les 20 ans
de la Chine dans l'OMC c'est-à-dire dans
20 ans de la Chine sur le marché pour
garde on a commis des erreurs
je pense 3 fois qu'on se voit parce que
ça c'est quand j'entends ça la naïveté
je parle assortiment ils ont pas ils ont
pas
les droits de l'homme ça on sera jamais
d'accord
donc
ça et puis
de l'avenir c'est la planète sur la
planète position
de Paris on a eu la le multilatéralisme
sur l'accord de Washington aujourd'hui
on peut peut-être avancer c'est la seule
lumière d'optimiste que je vois dans la
situation internationale c'est le
consensus sur la planète pour la planète
isation c'est un consensus aujourd'hui
qui est plus fort que celui de la
mondialisation pour terminer Jean-Pierre
Raffarin parce que je retourne oui
est-ce que tout ça toutes ces
difficultés Val de boycotter les Jeux
Olympiques je pense je pars prépare des
Jeux olympiques d'hiver
je pense que il faut chercher les
consensus le sport est un consensus des
sociétés civiles mondiale le sport peut
porter l'appel sport est un élément
constitutif faut porter les concepts
nous avons avec la je ne veux pas du
tout accepter les règles politique de la
chaîne je suis pas communiste je serai
jamais et je combattrai toujours le
comique mais
c'est pas Cuba la Chine c'est quand même
le premier moteur de croissance du monde
et qu'on a besoin c'est une vieille
civilisation donc on a les sujets qui
sont les sujets de conflit mais on a
aussi des sujets de coopération en tout
cas il faut pas se lancer dans cette
bataille des États-Unis il faut avoir de
l'influence sur nos propres convictions
et donc on a des je vais vous dire dans
mon dans ma mission de prison je m'en
vante pas je vous le dis comme ça entre
parenthèses parce que ça fait partie de
l'action qu'on doit faire mais c'est
l'influence qu'on a pour obtenir un
certain nombre de choses qui sont dans
nos valeurs mais mais ça donc il faut
pas céder sur nos valeurs il faut pas
céder sur ce nos convictions mais il
faut se dire aussi que on a des
entreprises on a un certain angle et on
a surtout un monde qui doit être
équilibré et la façon d'équilibrer le
monde c'est que l'Europe aujourd'hui
essaie d'être un intermédiaire entre ces
deux grandes puissances qui s'affrontent
et ils doivent pas savoir davantage sur
la merci beaucoup s'appelle votre livre
choisir un chef vous avez toujours pas
dit que vous allez choisir pour
son sur la table d'accord choisir ses
secrets du leadership c'est aux éditions
Michel Lafon merci à tous terminé on la
retrouve en rediffusion sur l'antenne
bien sûr on la retrouve en replay sur
les réseaux sociaux et puis sur le site
internet de rt France rt France. TV
Jean-Pierre Raffarin merci merci à tous
pour cette fidélité à très bientôt
[Musique]